i have something really special prepared
for my fans
doing an online performance it's called
studio 2054
it's not like the live show it's more
like a live music video it's quite
theatrical it's
something that i wouldn't be able to do
on stage so i have this opportunity to
kind of bring this
to um fans yes it's kind of like my own
tv show almost like my dream tv
show to just have people come down
there's like
costumes and performers and guest
performers and guest appearances and
lots of dancing and costume changes and
it's going to be a lot of fun and i'm
i'm so
excited so that's going to kind of tie
me over a little bit give me that
adrenaline that i've been missing so
much from tour
don't show up don't come out
dua had to postpone her future nostalgia
tour due to the coronavirus pandemic
it's really really hard like i made this
record to be able to go out there and
perform it and experience you know
the crowds and the people and it has
been quite
upsetting and like disheartening having
to move it but you know i totally
understand it's the way that things are
at the moment and hopefully we'll be
able to get together and celebrate
but she will be returning to the
american music awards stage as a
performer
and nominee november 22nd i'm going to
be filming mine from london we're going
to create something really really
special something exciting
something very british i don't want to
give too much away you know i'm really
excited i always like to keep my cards
close to my chest until the performance
comes out and
hopefully it'll be like a surprise to
people that's always my
aim and dua teased her much anticipated
collaboration with miley cyrus for
miley's album
out next month i love her she's really
really fun and
her energy is is unmatched and
we had a blast shooting this music video
it's fun it's playful i feel like it's a
perfect combination of the two of us
again i don't want to give too much away
i want to keep it a secret for a little
while longer
um but we're both really excited we just
like text each other and go oh my god we
can't wait like we're just ready so it's
going to be
it's going to be really fun i hope
everybody feels the same way
earlier this year duo released a remixed
version of her second album called
club future nostalgia with features from
madonna
missy elliott and gwen stefani it was
amazing
such such a dream come true you know
creating this
remix record with the blessed madonna
was something that i guess would never
have happened
if it wasn't for you know the pandemic
and everyone being at home and
having time to do this so i'm so so
grateful to
all the artists and all the producers
and djs and everybody that kind of took
part in this record to make it so
special it was really something that
i guess for me it's like a once in a
lifetime opportunity to get to create
something like this and
at normal time it just wouldn't have
been possible and so it was really
exciting and i learned
a lot from the process
you